dualipa is sued by the paparazzi because
she shared one of the paparazzi's photos
of dua lipa this sounds ridiculous
except for the fact that duolipo was the
one who was in the wrong
we see this actually a lot where
celebrities use a photo that's taken of
them thinking that they own the
intellectual property rights related to
it i think this happened to miley cyrus
and britney spears the thing is it's the
photographer who owns the copyright in
the photo even if you take a photo of
someone else often the paparazzi have a
right to take these photos you could
have two photographers taking a picture
of i don't know a tree and the photos
could look exactly the same
they could be taken at exactly the same
time and each of those photographers
owns the copyright in their particular
photo
and if you're taking a picture of a
person on the street it's not the person
on the street that owns that copyright
it's the person that took
the photo so just because you are the
subject of a photo doesn't mean that you
have the copyright and the ability to
post that photo on social media and
duallipa found out the hard way that
she didn't own the rights so if we see
dua lipa in court
she's probably going to lose this one